you mentioned relationships which I
imagine is where this is really like a
big issue because in normal life you can
distance yourself from people like that
you can choose a different job whatever
once you're in a relationship how does
how do you know that you are dealing
with someone who's full-blown NPD
well you know you can put a YouTube
video out saying how to know if you're
dealing with somebody who's MPD and
you're guaranteed to get like half a
million views in a year because
everybody's asking that question right
how do we know because if you're in love
with somebody and you start to realize
there's something up and you think it
could be narcissism
pretty bleak and so you hope that
they're just traumatized you hope they
just have PTSD and they're having bad
days because if it's NPD
there's really no hope
what I would say I would be looking for
patterns of exploitativeness and
entitlement that play out across
contacts and across time even when
you've told them to stop so if it seems
as though they'll just say yes yes yes
I'll stop I'll go to therapy I'll do
this I'll do that and do the other and
they're not stopping and they keep going
and you've told them it hurts and
they're still doing it it's not great
because even if they don't have MVD they
are an [ __ ]
which is which is just as good a reason
to split up with somebody as anything
else yeah you don't need the clinical
diagnosis these are these are boundaries
aren't they I would say like once you've
told somebody three or four times like
that thing that you're doing it really
hurts me you tell me that you love me
but you're still doing it three four
would you give them a fifth chance maybe
you would unless they've just been
through some major trauma in their lives
that justifies it I would say that's you
you're either looking at somebody who's
MPD or their idea of what it is to act
within a relationship that's loving and
intimate it's so hot because somebody
can just act narcissistically and it can
be context specific many people in this
culture have very narcissistic defense
mechanisms around love and dating how do
you mean
well we're in a tricky place as far as
the genders go right now and it's a bit
of a Battleground out there I know
you're both in happy relationships but
presumably before that you were dating I
never was you you were not first one
banned job done really yeah good for you
18 years old done good for you you saved
yourself a lot of trouble I imagine so
yeah it's it's brutal it's it's really
brutal and it's it's gotten noticeably
worse year on year of the last 20 years
but particularly in the last five years
it's become very Savage it's
Battleground as the genders as the Sexes
split apart and polarize the view of
each other has gotten darker and darker
talked about Shadow integration before
and Shadow possession as we become more
Shadow possessed we engage in something
called projective identification so you
just start seeing the other person is
awful even if they're not you have two
people who are ruined spoiled by
consumer capitalism trying to consume
each other narcissistically while using
protective identification see the worst
elements that they have onto the other
it's a nightmare to put some meat on
that skeleton what do you mean when you
say it's a Battleground and and all of
that like what are you talking about are
you talking about men and women starting
to be so more antagonistic or yes men
and women being more antagonistic but to
be fair I have heard that in the in the
gay scene it's the same thing so as far
as love and intimacy goes we've sort of
lost a grip on what it is to be in a
relationship and the Battleground is
I'm going to try and take as much foot
so we have a room full of people 100
people and they're all trying to date
each other but everybody's running a
program that says I'm going to take as
much from you as I possibly can and I
know you're going to hurt me because
everybody behind me has hurt me I'm just
waiting for when so people are coming in
armored and they're coming in with
weapons drawn assuming it's going to be
awful that's where the projective
identification comes in every single guy
I've ever been with has treated me like
[ __ ] you're a guy all the data I have
indicates you're getting to treat me
like Chef so the the hostility levels
start quite high it's defensive those
defenses are narcissistic typically so
it's it gets it just gets nasty really
really quickly so it's quite hostile so
if you meet somebody randomly say I meet
a girl and I meet her randomly and
there's no intent there and we're just
working together or something it'll be
fine but as soon as it's in a dating
context or she gets a sense that there
could be the potential for a
relationship then the defenses go up and
it gets hostile and it gets aggressive
quickly so the way people are treating
each other now is
is with contempt quite honestly and does
that factor in as well the the social
media element like we sue people as
avatars we don't see them as human
beings anymore 100 100 the
dehumanization that's operating broad
scale is having an awful effect on the
way people interact with each other
because as you've just said if I'm only
dealing with an avatar that Avatar is
either going to give me what I want or
they're not and if they don't they're a
defective Avatar they're an iPhone that
doesn't work properly or an app that
needs updating and I'm very cross and
I'm very frustrated that it's not giving
me what I want sad but that's what we're
our brains have been entrained to think
about life and relationships and and
people in a highly narcissistic way